yeah it looks like a sci-fi movie to me
yeah I got sight I know it's a sign
changer I'm saying this looks like
sci-fi channel were they doing I feel
like it's a little bit yeah I just feel
like it's a little late for this movie
and I almost wonder if this was held for
a while yeah reshot or beefed up for you
know whatever I I get this impression
this is going to fly what's going on
reject nation it's Greg Alva here and
it's 2:00 in the morning over here at
2:30 in the morning Laurie shot I am
spider-man homecoming review
you betcha wanted either quick mention
before we go into this Geo storm trailer
yes
Pizza add a shout out today it's gonna
go to Matt Wiles keep a lookout for that
and that'll be after the reaction I'm
running all right guys trailer reaction
first before the review for Roland
Emmerich's cheese yeah we know it's not
him don't work a couple guys listen
oh no since mini hear from Jacob Lawson
I'm at ISS chief coordinator mega record
reflect that he was nearly one hour late
yeah sorry about that
literally had to fly in from outer space
and your perfect American eggs a system
of satellites natural disasters will
become a thing of the past
we can control our weather how cool some
artists paint my thermos true except
lights malfunctioned over Afghanistan so
your proposal oh he shuts down all
family I don't need to remind all of you
how many people died he kind of stopped
the climate condition which was no for
the residents hey going back up space
coming back from a trip sir just don't
touch anything kind of astronomical the
jegos is viewed which older than it
would have fallen I mean good access is
the block does that comment
it started a little frozen in contention
we widen this potential catastrophic
weather events on a global feel a GU
story we have to shut the system down
partly by moving as the cocodes is the
president any year now you're soliciting
a Secret Service agent
seriously we're kidnapping the president
and a self-driving cat what is this well
yes you can't stop it
[Music]
to
[Music]
yeah I can't have the president I stole
state secret you see anything i'm
forgetting honey honey ha ha
that was a that was just a regular
disastrous and that was a natural Glenn
crane fell over I feel like at some
point that trailer was every trailer
I've seen but I think that trailer is
what we call in Hollywood a misleading
trailer but in which direction I do not
know okay here's what I think is
happening right this is a trailer for
the first one do many of these do this
first trailer didn't we want you
together no I thought by myself oh no
yeah it was like serious dark epic with
exactly roland emmerich ii all right
which makes sense in one of the
directors produced like three roland
emmerich oh yeah for something like that
actually then when I started to see this
trailer I'm like this looks like what
Roland Emmerich films turn into they
were trying to develop a trailer that
can resemble more of the silly type of
films they actually are I'm saying
misleading in the sense that I think
they're trying to make this look like
it's intentionally gonna feel this way I
feel like films like this have the habit
of trying to be epic serious because
it's dealing with disasters but
oftentimes they can feel kind of silly
and the way the characters behave and
now they react to situations jokes that
go on in situations that would it really
have jokes and stories like it yeah
what is that humor tell me that was my
theory okay I know you got to see the
actual film before you judge this is
just my theory is what we're getting off
this here representation of William who
he has with two very different trailers
yeah well I don't know and for the first
half of this trailer I was actually kind
of surprised so okay this is busca de
Ghent yeah like space harp is ruining
the world and that's a cool idea like
these these weather controlling we can
control weather on earth yeah go ahead
that's bound to go wrong because that's
what happens when you try to mess with
nature you try to control nature did you
guys not see Jurassic world you can't
put two dinosaurs together through that
and then you know the humor starts
coming and then the
is a cool rock music company yeah and
then it looked like it was getting
serious again and then I went all
rock-and-roll during like all millions
of people done after tomorrow
yeah well yeah well - I grew exactly
planes falling from the sky and I really
like the marketing people behind the
scenes are trying to like well maybe now
if we're just upfront about what this
totally might actually come across like
the music and everything in the way that
it seemed like an edited trailer it
seemed like a trailer that was trying to
make it look like something that it was
not how do we best sell each part of
this movie as how I felt yeah because I
don't know maybe yeah maybe the movie
starts off grounded in a way and just
goes berserk or something that that's
what I got from this because this is not
I mean like the way it's all being shot
and even if it seems a dialogue of humor
seem like adventure disaster film at the
same time though I don't think P
millions of people or thousands are like
being wiped out by these disasters cults
or this kind of tone to happen yeah like
the first trailer represents more of
what they probably wanted to feel like I
get it yeah that's probably what they're
going for with the movie you know like
say say what you will about San Andreas
but that movie is pretty much horrifying
the entire time and it's kind of pitched
that way at least I remember being
pitched that way and this is that kind
of disaster movie at all out and Gerard
Butler is in space yeah forget in the
spaceship they say don't touch anything
I cook gonna ask her out is entire basin
far a lot of a kitchen should go give
them a shout out actually the one is
great my sister went to school with her
that's amazing yeah that's cool it looks
like they they're gonna have both kinds
of movie like like some kind of space
model movie but also you know in 2012
style like we're zipping it around in
the car with the president trying to get
out of air like I guess the reason I'm
harping on this so much is I get the
impression that tone is not going to be
well executed in this fell then the
disaster sequences don't even look that
great to me well it bothers me in these
kinds of movies at least it what keeps
me from getting really invested is
when we see a lot of the destruction
from the big scale and not as much on
the ground because if you only see it
from afar it feels like you're a feel
crunch and you're not connected to it
well so I appreciate it it's really
trying to make it about the people I
appreciated that yeah honestly I do
appreciate that I trying to make it
about the characters in the situation of
trying to deal with I could be wrong I
feel like I'm usually not but I I could
be wrong and I mean I like Gerard Butler
I do Thailand
Saab but I want good items for him
however I don't like his movies and and
and you know other people said this
before me but I do think it's true it's
like there's something about him I like
Gerard Butler I don't trust his judgment
and so my movies he does yeah so most of
the time it's like it's like Corey from
the hotels we put a bet he's like every
time do our Butler runs across camera
you're like you're charming I like you
but he's always got that look of like
you know momentum yeah and I feel like
that's what he gets
at best this could be fun if they
deliver on the fun this could be cool I
don't think this is in salvageable and I
think the concept is really cool and the
early stuff in the trailer like when
they're in in Afghanistan the soldiers a
frozen those were like oh yeah it's
really yeah chilling imagery to look at
no pun intended but yeah the later stuff
I'm like it's gonna get silly and CG and
over-the-top and bonkers and looks like
it might yeah I mean like that imagery
when the guy is frozen in the snow that
was really cool no pun intended I was
like 95% what I that exact same joke
Emmet
yeah I think this movie's gonna be a
flop I really think that don't say I
like every trailer
don't say I like every 10 because I am
being Austin to guys I don't if you want
to go out there and defend this movie
okay god glad someone's looking forward
to it as well before we close out the
video Matt Wiles got to give you a shout
out buddy that while I'm so curious as
to why you don't show your face to us
ever you've been part of our patreon for
a while now you just haven't shown us
what you even look like I'm so curious
to see your face
that Lyle's is not in the profile
it's a mystery like the x-file show it's
your face subscribe to the real region
great click on that notification bill
John is dad John Humphrey on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of Blum
House like and share this video comment
in the comment boxes check out all our
awesome perks and rewards over on
patreon.com slash the real rejects a key
TPS those two dot slash slash maybe a
couple of things
WW patreon.com slash the real rejects
what is it John WWE ENCOM slash the real
rejected else's on t-shirt those are on
Spreadshirt car / the real reasoning I
never mentioned take care yeah
oh and check out comedy sketches on Lana
McKissack channel cuz their husband in
this trip helping out I hello to Ray it
was ok to help out a fellow YouTube one
of my never expressed so wish to do that
my life